it's 9:00 at night and I'm never going
to sleep
hi guys my name is Tara chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen and today as
promised I am watching the neverending
story
it seems very dark crystally to me which
was pretty and impressive but just
something that didn't interest me like
it's not going to change my world like
John wick did Wow Tamara you have such
good taste boobies thanks Tamara I know
here we go oh that was what I expected
it to be it was really cool looking
story-wise and acting wise it just
didn't blow me away I don't think this
is a genre for me that I relate to
though I recognized what cool aspects to
make it a whole entity in itself that
didn't make any sense you know and you
know I just is not my thing
his mom has died and I couldn't pay
attention to anything that was happening
on-screen because the dad was making a
breakfast smoothie of orange juice and
an egg today
cracked open that thing that's just
directed me so much again it's a very
end the credits are rolling and I was
like that egg pellet so if the kid is
named Bastian and there's the whole
story plot where there's three boys and
they're gonna get in there like oh the
weirdo when they go into Jason and they
throw them in a dumpster and you're like
all right well eighties movies then you
find out that this little weirdo loves
books and like oh I like you or you
seals the neverending story which is
this mysterious book at the bookstore so
you're in the world of the neverending
story and Fantasia Fantasia notice hope
the practical effectiveness are
incredible you get introduced to the
rockbiter holy crab them so cool its
face looks like the new snapchat filter
your mouth is huge there's a great big
snail that reminded me of Ike and you
keep getting introduced to these really
incredible
the imaginative creatures you go to the
the Empress's castle and there are these
giant heads and like these people who
have like three tempered head like just
crazy cool creatures that if I had seen
fit to the child I would have been
really scared I wish that the story was
about those creature versus these like
bland young children who weren't
interesting to me
everything was just really predictable -
they're like the Emperor's is the only
one who can save us - two seconds later
the Empress is very sick and cannot save
you so they are like wow we've sent for
this great warrior I need to try you and
then Atreyu shows up and he's like five
and not really five 8s they're like
really confused which I need that make
sense he's like no I can do it
and so they send to try you off to save
the entirety of their universe a trio is
talking to his horse
artax and he's like oh you want to eat
it's a good idea and then you cut back -
but steel and watches his name fatty
this deal that kid and he's like no it's
a great idea he just acted to snuff kids
but I Cristian not excellent at acting
but so thank you I mean if you got it
flaunt it so nervous sadness swamp and
this is awesome lion they're like
everyone knew whoever let the sadness
overtake him would sink into the swamp
stay with Edna Solano then our tags died
and this is a theme that I've definitely
seen I knew was coming I didn't think
was meeting this early on I didn't know
him at all he was just a mere horse to
me oh it didn't make me sad and everyone
painted it out to me I thought it was
gonna be like crying at the scene let me
tell you I'm an easy crier in movies but
I do like and I am intrigued about how
darkness the movie is this poor kid is
great bawling his eyes out what she's a
way better actor than bastian 'as horses
but dying in front of in this it is
tragic
it just wasn't haunted the way I thought
it was gonna be presented but I think my
favorite line in the entire movie
is fight against the sadness architect
condemns and movies animal deaths are so
much more impactful than cumin depths
because they love you unconditionally
and don't judge you it's just I mean
it's more sad so I can fall out when
somebody shoots my companion dogmeat put
the dog I get very mad and I yell with
them don't touch my dog same thing I
feel like there's the exact same then
you meet more love the turtle
how many pet turtles are named that I
mean if you have a turtle and you've
seen this movie you have to name your
turtle Morla so Bastian screams when the
turtle is revealed because it scares him
and I do love how engaged he is in
reading this book
there's not even pictures like no kid
and the fiction of children whatever I
just it's very 80s but he screams and
they hear him in in the neverending
story world and she goes but that's
impossible
they couldn't have heard me again
quality acting also he'd ate and I being
a giant butthole I feel like in the 80s
like it wasn't a giant priority to get a
good actor as a child if I see a new
movie that's out now and the child or
they like younger actors aren't good I'm
just totally taken out of it also more
or less pieces are hilarious I like her
a lot more line and I would be a veteran
thus coolest out and Bastian has skipped
school to read this book that he stole
where where where is he it's got like
skeletons and like animal carcasses and
but like also brooms
what is this multi-purpose room so
Atreyu is just really like going through
it like he's juggling he's about to pass
out and then Fowler comes to the rescue
of the Falkor is this giant
english-speaking doctor dog who flies in
college I had a friend who had a dog
named Falkor and the first time we went
over to her house she's like oh my dog's
name is south core and I would like that
such a great name and I pretended like I
didn't want to ask what it meant
like yes so great and now I get it so I
wrote south or is also sassy low voice
and he wink a lot sophomore is like
hanging out with this couple who they're
elves I don't know what they are I was
like in all the sets at this point there
is that telescope at the cool crystals
coming out it that was awesome like just
set and and the pepper tree and are they
puppets and then the makeup and just
like the crashes all effects um is are
really impressive I feel like now you
get a cool story and great acting with
CGI and then you got like awesome
practical effects that were super
engaging story and acting we're just
kind of that's probably my experience I
don't think that's true I just think
that's how I really love though that
they say if you don't know your own
self-worth you can't go to the work then
there's a mirror lead us to face and
confronted with their true selves most
men run away screaming I thought that
was awesome - what a cool visual if you
like actually see yourself for who you
are then you're not gonna like it that's
awesome
the only way that they can passively
save the kingdom is to be shown in child
against the Empress a new name where
could they ever find a human child the
cheesiness wouldn't have bothered music
in but now I'm just like Atreyu ends up
running into the rockbiter and a trade
is like it's my fault when the rock
ladders like put my hands I thought they
were good hands
then it's kind of a sad moment though
sometimes my hands they don't feel like
my own I need someone to lose I need
someone to hold that what's that okay
alright Cameron don't be such a jerk
nothing were strong against sorry guy he
runs into the morgue Gamora is like well
there's no boundaries to Fantasia so
you'll never find the child and the kid
is like how do you know that and good
work is like cuz dum-dum I just do I
just like how is this boy the hero of
this story he doesn't fight anything
he's not a warrior his horse just
straight up gives up he's like I don't
care to be with you anymore goodbye he
knows nothing
Fantasia the place he is from and is
trying to say no credential no one's
made and all he does is cry and whine
how I'm here oh sorry what I know that
Bastian is the hero of the story but but
this is the one we're following this kid
around I wrote I'm all about young
heroes but he isn't helping with
anything so he somehow kills Mork with a
stick or something I roll a somehow find
the entrance even though Oliphant age is
falling apart and the Empress is
beautiful she has perfect eyebrows and
lips
despite being six years old seemingly
Atreyu and the Empress both look like
cover models for trashy romantic novels
so the Empress is like the human has
been with you all along and all he has
to do is realize that he's part of the
story of the neverending story and call
out my new name and all will be saved
and then all of Fantasia just falls
apart as destroyed and Bastian finally
gets the courage and calls out his name
and his mother's name I guess I didn't
actually hear the name and he used his
yelling I have subtitles on and the
subtitles were like screaming there but
there wasn't a name it did I just miss
it I think so
probably on me so he then imagines a new
Fantasia and then southward like
anything else and he's like hell yeah
and they go I mean she took the three
bullies the visual effects the practical
side to work in incredible Southport I
want him and I think I want to get a lot
of crap for this because everyone loves
this movie so much I didn't hate it I
did not love it though I have no idea
what I'm gonna do next week I'm thinking
I'd love to do something animated so
maybe you like spirited away so let me
know what you two good to do and the
comments below thank you so much for
watching and I will see you next week
bye
this is my Falkor do you know where
beyond Fantasia is sort of more doodle
[Music]